Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Ce matin, quand je me suis réveillé,
la première chose que j’ai fait,
comme d’habitude,
c’est regarder mon téléphone.
Dans mon fil d’actualités, j’avais
une suggestion d’article qui me disait
que cet été,
la mode serait au T-shirt brodé.
Alors, je me suis levé content,
je savais ce que je porterais aujourd’hui.
Il a fallu que j’attende un peu,
que je prenne mon café du matin,
pour me rendre compte
de ce que je venais de faire.
Je venais de laisser à mon téléphone
le soin de choisir la tenue
que je porterai aujourd’hui.
Je me suis vu un peu
comme dans ce dessin animé de Pixar,
Wall-E, où les humains, complètement
asservis par leur technologie,
changent la couleur de leur combinaison
parce qu’un ordinateur dicte
que la tendance est au bleu
plutôt qu’au rouge aujourd’hui.
Et là, plein d’images ont commencé
à tournoyer dans ma tête.
Des images d’un futur
peut-être pas si lointain,
dans lequel la technologie déciderait
non seulement de ce que je porte,
mais peut-être aussi de nos lois
ou des opportunités
qui s’offrent à moi dans ma vie.
Projetons-nous un peu dans un monde
à La Bienvenue à Gattaca,
ce film où, parce qu’un ordinateur
a prédit que le personnage principal
serait susceptible de développer
des maladies pendant sa vie,
alors un pan entier
de carrière professionnelle
lui serait fermé pour toujours.
Projetons-nous un peu dans un monde
à la 1984 de George Orwell
ou des Temps Modernes de Chaplin,
où des machines nous surveilleraient
en permanence
et nous enverraient des rappels à l’ordre
si notre comportement ne suivait pas
une norme préétablie.
Le futur que je vous décris vous effraie ?
Ou est-ce qu’au contraire vous vous dites
que je suis un peu alarmiste,
que je décris de la pure fiction
qui n’arrivera jamais ?
Pourtant, dans de nombreux domaines,
nous avons déjà sacrifié, au profit
de la machine, une part de nos décisions.
Mais avant d’y revenir,
demandons-nous plutôt comment,
comment une machine
peut-elle apprendre à faire
quelque chose qui nous prend à nous,
humains, des années à maîtriser ?
Comment peut-elle prédire
les tendances de la mode
ou battre un maître aux échecs ?
Eh bien, cette machine, appelons-la
intelligence artificielle ou IA,
et c’est un programme informatique
que je vous propose de voir
comme une fusée.
Alors cette fusée en elle-même,
elle ne sert à rien
si on ne fixe pas d’objectif :
aller sur la Lune,
aller en orbite autour de Saturne.
Et cet objectif, dans le monde
de l’intelligence artificielle,
c’est la tâche que l’on cherche
à rendre automatique.
Est-ce que je vais vouloir
prédire la susceptibilité
de développer une maladie
ou trouver mon chemin dans la rue ?
Soyons déjà d’accord sur un point :
il n’existe pas aujourd’hui
de fusée magique
qui atteindrait tous les objectifs.
Autrement dit,
pour des finalités différentes,
l’intelligence artificielle
que nous créerons sera différente.
Nous sommes bien loin encore
de la versatilité que nous seuls, humains,
pouvons faire preuve.
Mais avoir une fusée bien conçue
est une chose.
Pour qu’elle atteigne son objectif,
il lui faut également du carburant.
Et ce carburant dans le monde
de l’intelligence artificielle,
ce sont les données.
Les données lui servent d’exemples
sur la manière d’atteindre l’objectif
dans un cas précis.
Je pourrai ainsi expliquer à mon téléphone
le chemin que j’ai suivi ce matin
pour aller chez mon boulanger
et il pourra réutiliser cette information
pour savoir comment me guider
d’un point A à un point B.
Pour peu qu’elle ait
suffisamment de données,
l’intelligence artificielle
saura atteindre l’objectif
dans une grande variété de situations.
C’est sur ce principe
que l’intelligence artificielle
nous permet de rendre plus simples
et plus automatiques
une grande variété de tâches rébarbatives
de notre quotidien.
C'est ce qui a fait la clé de son succès.
Pensons-y un instant.
C’est indéniablement
un succès retentissant.
Qui parmi vous, ne dégaine pas
spontanément son smartphone
lorsqu’il s’agit de se repérer
dans la rue ?
Qui parmi vous cherche encore
ses prochains vêtements,
son prochain logement
ou ce qu’il va manger ce soir
sans passer par des moteurs
de recommandation ou de recherche
qui prémâcheront le travail ?
Et ça va encore plus loin,
parce que l’IA, c’est du confort
et de la sécurité gagnés au quotidien.
Parmi vous, je sais que vous êtes
de plus en plus nombreux
à demander à la maison,
à votre assistant vocal,
d’allumer la lumière du salon,
de passer la musique
ou tout simplement de vous rappeler
que vous avez rendez-vous
chez le médecin demain matin.
Mais pensons-y un peu.
Le temps et le confort gagnés
en rendant automatique ces tâches,
ne l’avons-nous pas payé au prix
d’un peu de notre libre arbitre ?
Ne sommes-nous pas devenus
un peu paresseux
et n’aurions-nous pas perdu
un peu de notre intelligence
en la sacrifiant au profit de la machine ?
Beaucoup d’entre vous
sont suffisamment âgés
pour avoir vécu le développement
de l’intelligence artificielle
et sa croissance, jusqu’à prendre
une part si importante
dans nos vies de tous les jours.
Nous avons tous encore en tête
des mémoires d’un temps
où nous étions plus jeunes,
moins dépendants de la technologie,
moins connectés, nous pourrons
toujours nous y référer.
Qu’en sera-t-il pour nos enfants ?
Eux naissent et grandissent dans un monde
déjà largement dominé par la technologie.
Il leur sera d'autant plus difficile
d'imaginer vivre autrement.
Pour eux et pour nous tous,
nous comprenons que savoir où je place
le curseur entre le confort et la sécurité
gagnés grâce à l’intelligence artificielle
et la part de libre arbitre
que je lui sacrifie, est très complexe.
Alors face à cette complexité
et ce risque pour notre humanité,
devrions-nous dire stop ?
Stop, on arrête de développer l’IA,
on ne fait plus rien, on s’arrête là.
Est-ce qu’on y perdrait quelque chose ?
Dans de nombreux domaines,
l’IA est déjà bien régulée
et elle permet d’assister l’humain
sans pour autant remplacer
son expertise ou ses valeurs.
Dans le domaine de la santé,
certaines technologies peuvent,
sur la base d’une image IRM,
d’une image radio, d’un scanner,
guider le médecin vers un diagnostic
plus précis, et ce au bénéfice du patient.
Pensez-vous que de telles technologies
peuvent voir le jour
si seuls des experts
de l’intelligence artificielle
œuvrent à les développer ?
Non.
Pour que ce système puisse fonctionner
et rester utile et respectueux de tous,
ces experts travaillent avec des experts
de l’imagerie médicale, des médecins,
des patients.
Et c’est ensemble, entre personnes
directement concernées
par ces technologies et leur utilisation
que nous pouvons garantir de concevoir
cette IA utile pour tous.
C'est donc ensemble que nous devons
définir les règles du jeu de l'IA.
Il ne s’agit pas simplement
de poser des limites à l’IA
et lui interdire
certains champs d’application,
mais plus simplement
que chacun se sente légitime,
quelles que soient ses compétences,
pour dire ce pour quoi il a besoin
de l’IA dans sa vie.
Alors ce que je suis en train de dire
peut vous paraître simple
quand on a un diplôme en informatique
et que ces système
nous sont très familiers.
Cela voudrait dire que nous devrions
exclure du débat
toutes les personnes sans diplôme ?
Devrions-nous exclure nos enfants ?
Les personnes qui ne parlent pas
notre langue
ou qui partagent une culture
différente de la nôtre ?
Comment les impliquer ?
Eh bien, revenons
à cette définition de l’IA,
ce programme informatique qui cherche
à atteindre un objectif
grâce à des données.
Alors, certes, nous n’avons pas tous
les compétences
pour contribuer à développer
ce programme informatique.
Mais la finalité pour laquelle
nous développons l’IA
et les données que nous lui confions,
ce sont également bien
des humains qui l’ont définie.
Et pour cela, nous sommes tous légitimes.
Ce n’est pas au gouvernement
ou aux grandes entreprises
de décider pour nous
quelles seront les finalités
pour lesquelles
nous voulons voir l’IA développée.
Afin d’éviter les risques de dérives,
cette volonté doit venir d’un engagement
citoyen de chacun de nous.
Certains définissent aujourd’hui l’IA
comme la nouvelle électricité,
cette énergie qui décuplerait
nos capacités
lorsqu’elle aura alimenté
tous les pans de notre vie quotidienne.
Et quand on voit les enjeux stratégiques
dont fait l’objet
l’approvisionnement en énergie,
on comprend aujourd’hui à quel point
nous en sommes dépendants.
Et on comprend qu’il est essentiel
de lancer dès à présent
ce débat sur la place
qu’aura l’IA dans notre société.
Pour le confort et la sécurité
qu’elle apporte,
nous devons nous assurer de déployer l’IA
partout où elle est nécessaire,
mais pour les risques qu’elle pose,
garantissons aussi de la déployer
seulement là où c’est nécessaire.
Et si nous voulons y parvenir, l'IA doit
devenir notre bien commun à tous.
Ce que je vous propose ici,
c’est finalement de partir
pour une quête de cohérence,
de cohérence dans la relation
que nous entretenons
avec cette technologie
déjà si importante dans notre vie
et dont l’importance
est encore amenée à grandir.
Mais si nous sommes convaincus du devoir
d’agir, comment le faire concrètement ?
Alors nous avons parlé plus tôt de lois,
de normes pour mieux encadrer l’IA.
Et c'est un début.
Mais pour que cet objectif soit pérennisé,
assurons-nous aussi d’éduquer à l’IA
le plus grand nombre
et surtout nos enfants.
Montrons-leur les opportunités
qu’offre l’IA
mais également les risques qu’elle pose
pour notre humanité.
Nous avons également intérêt, tous,
gouvernements, grandes entreprises,
individus, à rester transparents
sur la finalité
pour laquelle nous déployons l’IA.
Et nous devons aussi rendre accessible
à tous, sans prérequis de connaissance,
la contribution à chacune des étapes
de la conception
de l’intelligence artificielle,
depuis l’idée initiale
jusqu’à sa diffusion
dans notre vie quotidienne.
Créons des espaces de partage,
des moments de partage
pour échanger ensemble
sur la construction de cette IA
Je rêve de cafés IA ou de hubs IA,
où chacun pourrait venir
avec ses compétences,
ses connaissances ou bien simplement
ses idées et ses besoins,
pour échanger ensemble
et construire une solution
qui soit vraiment en cohérence
avec les besoins
que nous avons réellement.
C’est seulement tous ensemble,
entre personnes de valeurs
et compétences diverses,
et pas seulement entre experts,
que nous créerons
une intelligence artificielle
qui soit véritablement
au service de l’humain et pas l’inverse.
Alors, puisque nous sommes tous
concernés par cet enjeu,
soyons-en tous acteurs.
Merci.